go to a bar have some fun together as
friends I didn't see you pull back at
all you is I'm sorry killing you guys
well I'm not sorry for kill him wait
that was a purpose station light on the
back of it it flashes blue and red yeah
wait we're honor we're this bad [ __ ] no
stupid haircut scrape him off on the
road he was there music
carpe diem you know seize the day but
for that you just threw him into my
crotch this is
but I will not okay one record left oh
there's a cop behind you there was
killed
oh you didn't I see crotch right visit
on the helicopter
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
if we miss each other we can go to the
top of the building expert flying well
you better be there by the time we get
there
[Music]
[Music]
I'll try not to l2 or to control have no
control this is not good we did what we
set out to do and I'm proud to say we if
you guys watching have liked ideas for
what you want to see us do cuz there's
tons of people that play this game for a
living on YouTube and they've done some
[ __ ] so like give us some ideas always
we'll see you in the next video
[Music]